So I made a few changes to the code, see
if you agree with them. In the draw square function,
I now use a loop, and this loop does my
repetitive tasks, tasks like move the turtle forward and turn it
right, and this loop runs 4 times. Then I created
a new function called draw art, in this function I
create the window screen. This is the screen that has
the background color as red, and then I create my first
turtle, which I named brad. I change brad's shape,
color and speed, and then I call the draw square
function, so that I can actually draw my first
square. After that, I create my second turtle, angie. And
here are angie shape and color, and then angie
draws a circle. And then towards the end, I call
the draw_art function which is right here. So let
me go ahead and save, and run this program to
make sure everything is running fine. And there's our two
turtles. One drawing a square, the other one drawing a circle.